what we're going to do using our powers
of calculus is find the area of this
yellow region and if at any point you
get inspired I always encourage you to
pause the video and try to work through
it on your own so the key here is you
might recognize hey this is an area
between curves a definite integral might
be useful so I'll just set up the
definite integral sign and so first we
need to think about what are our left
and right boundaries of our region well
it looks like the left boundary is where
the two graphs intersect right over here
and the right boundaries were they
intersect right over there
well what is this point of intersection
it looks like it is negative 1 comma
negative 2 we can verify that in this
red curve if X is negative 1 let's see
you square that she'll get 1 minus 3 you
do indeed get Y is equal to negative 2
and in this blue function is X is equal
to negative 1 you get 1 minus 4 plus 1
once again you do indeed get Y is equal
to negative 2 and the same thing is true
when X is equal to 1 1 minus 3 negative
2 1 minus 4 plus 1 negative 2 so our
bounds are indeed we're going from x
equals negative 1 to x equals positive 1
and now let's think about our upper and
lower bounds over that interval this
blue graph is our upper bound and so we
would subtract the lower bound from the
upper bound so we would have X to the
4th minus 4 x squared plus 1 and from
that we will subtract x squared minus 3
DX and in many other videos we have
talked about why you do this why this
makes sense to just subtract the lower
graph from the upper graph when you're
finding the area between them but now we
just have to evaluate this definite
integral so let's just get down to
business all right
so we have the integral from negative 1
to 1 and so we have X to the fourth X to
the fourth and now we have minus 4 x
squared and then when you distribute
this negative sign you're gonna have
you're gonna subtract another x squared
you're gonna have minus 5 x squared and
then you have plus 1 and then you're
gonna subtract a negative 3
so it's going to be one plus three so
it's going to be plus four DX DX and
just to be clear I should put
parentheses right over there because
it's really the DX is being multiplied
by this entire expression and so let's
see let's find the antiderivative of
this this should be pretty
straightforward we're just going to use
the reverse power rule multiple times so
this is going to be the antiderivative
of X to the fourth is X to the fifth
over five we just incremented the
exponent and divided by that incremented
exponent - same idea here five X to the
third over three plus four X and then we
are going to evaluate it at 1 and then
subtract from that it evaluated at
negative one so let's first evaluate it
at one we're gonna get 1/5 minus 5/3
plus four and now let us evaluate it at
negative one so - let's see if this is
negative one we're gonna negative
one-fifth negative one-fifth and this is
going to be plus 5/3 plus 5/3 and then
this is going to be minus four minus
four but then when you distribute the
negative sign this so we're going to
distribute this over all of these terms
and so this is going to be four make
this positive this will be positive this
one will be negative and then this one
will be positive so you have 1/5 plus
1/5 which is going to be 2/5 that and
that and then minus 5/3 minus 5/3 so
minus 10 over 3 and then 4 plus 4 so
plus 8 and though so we just need to
simplify this this is going to be let's
see it's going to be 8 and then if I
write so plus I'm gonna write these two
with a denominator of 15 because that's
the common denominator of 3 and 5
I'll see 2/5 is 6 15 less yeah that's
right 5 times 3 is 15 2 times 3 is 6 and
then 10 thirds let's see if we multiply
the denominator times 5 after multiply
numerator times 5 so there's gonna be 50
15 and so what's 6 15 minus 50 15 so
this is going to be equal to 8 minus 6
minus 50 is minus 44 minus 44 over 15
and so what is 44 over 15 44 over 15 is
equal to 2 and 14 15 so that's really
what we're subtracting we're gonna
subtract 2 and 14 15 so if you subtract
2 from this you would get 6 minus 14
over 15 because we still have to
subtract the 14 15 and then 6 minus 14
15 is going to be equal to 5 and 1 15th
so just like that we were indeed able to
figure out this area